uh actually there's data on that if
you're a pessimist can you learn to be
an optimist and there's research done by
felony Martin seldingman at University
of Pennsylvania
who developed a field called positive
psychology
uh he developed the field because
psychology for 80 years only studied
pathology
there was a problem we hadn't noticed
that there was a positive spectrum of
emotion and experience but at any rate
Seligman took kids who were prone to
depression turned out that they tended
to to be pessimists and to see if they
had something that didn't work out or a
setback in life they'd say it's because
of me and I'll always be like that and
he taught them to think differently
while it was the circumstance
circumstances can change and I can do
something to change them it's a more
optimistic Outlook and he found that
actually after about a year their
thinking patterns had changed but it's
what I said as with any such Behavior we
have to keep at it and keep at it at
every naturally occurring opportunity
and catch ourselves when we go back to
the you know the old pattern
so yes optimism can be learned I
actually
Know Thee the gentleman who invented
cognitive therapy cognitive therapy
looks at our thinking distorted thinking
patterns and helps us see more
realistically and it's very effective
for depression
his name is Aaron Beck he's 93 now he
had a terrible accident that put him in
a wheelchair
and happened to speak to him after that
and he was very upbeat he suppose one of
the most optimistic people I know then
he lost sight in one eye and I was
talking to him he said well you know my
right eye works perfectly fine I can
still remember and then he went blind in
his right eye and he said you know I can
still listen to books on tape in other
words
he had the capacity to see what was
right instead of what's wrong which is
what you're talking about
yes
I just had a question about the
performance graph that you have there
yeah you mentioned two extremes you have
the unmotivated yeah performance end and
then you have the frazzle land yes what
can you do if you're one of those types
of people what can I do how can you
improve your what we can do with this
type of person and with this type of
person yeah
well let me ask you in this hypothetical
question are we this type of person are
we managing this type of person
or a friend of this who are we are we
the person a friend of this type of
person we're a friend under motivated I
have a friend here yeah I'd say always
so
what the person needs who is under
aroused who's disengaged is involvement
to get more
motivated more passionate more engaged
and
there's some there's a literature now on
something called good work good work
combines three things it combines what
we're really good at our excellence
with what we're really passionate about
what engages us and what we value with
our ethics if you align those three
things you're naturally going to go up
from here to there in fact you'll you'll
get into flow much more easily so one
question to ask our friend is
what would be good work for you and what
could you do to make it a larger
proportion of the time in your day or
your week or your month or over the
course of the next five years of your
career
so so that's a kind of individual
strategy for that
if you're here
if you're frazzle in frazzle what you
need is calm
so which is very related to cognitive
control but there are many ways to calm
down however
if you can't well there are two
strategies if you're say frazzle because
you have a boss that asks you to do too
much in too little time and give too
little support you might get your boss's
CV and send it out to a headhunter
but that's not an immediate solution so
instead you might manage your own world
better by finding something that works
for you that gets you physiologically
relaxed
it might be meditation it might be yoga
it might be deep muscle it might be
working out at the gym everyone is
different
do it every day
and do it before you go to work
or whatever is frazzling you because
what happens is that over time your body
set point for for stress changes and
you'll be able to manage better or to be
in a more relaxed state in in the
circumstance two general strategies yes
I've got two quick questions the first
one might be a silly question so I
apologize if I've missed this but do you
see Focus as an extension of emotional
intelligence or is it cognitive or is it
is it both right so what I think is that
attention was embedded within emotional
intelligence because the brain circuits
for emotions for empathy and for
attention intermingle I just never
thought about it
I didn't realize I had to write a whole
new book about it until I read it okay
the second question is I've got a
two-year-old son oh when he's four I
fully intend to do the marshmallow
experience I'm just wondering between
now and then are there things that I
could be doing for him but we'll help
him more be more likely to wait
um you're probably doing them already
just being a good enough parent
it's terrific yeah but pay attention to
you know your your child's feelings
needs
that's very important I wasn't entirely
surprised to hear this from a friend a
little while ago who works in the
psychiatric resident hospital and the
difference between the emotions of the
sexes is absolutely enormous
if a woman comes in for a session
um the psychotherapist will say how's it
going how are you and I will come
exactly how it's going how they feel
when a man comes in
very little is said so the
psychotherapist will say on the sofa
over there are a collection of soft toys
pick one up so the man will go and pick
up the panda
and the psychotherapist will say well
how is Mr Panda today and then it will
come so the difference of emotions
between the Sexes however we like to
think we are basically all the same I
think we are hugely different
so do I thank you
well I just wanted to make a response to
the gentleman with the two-year-old
because I have three children and I'm
sure that of all three coming out of
exactly the same
um environment probably would react very
differently to the marshmallow test so
that goes back to my question is it
learned or innate and I think often that
some people just have a natural
emotional intelligence oh yes I I didn't
answer your question the answer is it's
both learned and innate
in that each of us is born with a a
particular range of set points in the
brain chemicals that manage emotion
that's our temperament
and as you know if you have more than
one child kids differ from day one on
the other hand
epigenetics tells us that it's not the
genes you have it's which genes turn on
and off that will make the lasting
difference and the behavior in a child
is very malleable so if a child is very
impulsive that child can learn cognitive
control if a child is too constricted
that child could learn
to loosen up there's data on children
for example who are what are called
behaviorally inhibited this is work of
Jerome Kagan at Harvard he finds that
about 15 percent of children are anxious
about new stimuli new playground new
friend new food and when they're very
young these are the kids who at school
age are identified as shy
and it had been thought that this was
just genetic but what they he realized
when he followed a group of these kids
was it some of them by school age
weren't shy and he looked at the
parenting they got and he noted he found
that the difference was this if your
parents identify you as
she's shy and protect you those are the
children who don't change if parents say
to a child well you may feel a little
timid about it but go ahead and try it
anyway
that child learns I'll feel a little
scared at first but if I go ahead I'm
going to have a good time
and those are the children who don't end
up Shy so it's it's a a malleable mix of
both